[Music]
one day Mars could look like
this allowing humans to comfortably live
on the planet all we'd need to do is to
terraform it but
how well we could nuke
it would dropping nukes on Mars make it
easier to live
there this is what if and here's what
would happen if we nuked
Mars believe it or not this is something
scientists have considered for
decades Elon Musk of SpaceX seems to
think that nuking Mars might be one of
the best and quickest options to make it
a place where humans could live the idea
is that we would explode thermonuclear
bombs in the sky over the planet's Two
Poles this would heat up the ice caps
and release carbon dioxide and water
from the poles then the greenhouse
effect would take place it would heat up
the whole planet making the surface more
habitable so this all sounds super quick
and easy
why haven't we done this
yet it's because there's a high chance
that nuking Mars might not work out the
way we want it to there are many things
that could go wrong with this plan the
first problem is it's all just Theory
and the theory could be wrong that's
because Mars has been losing its
atmosphere for a long time Earth's
atmosphere is almost 100 times thicker
than Mars's and if we're going to live
on Mars it needs a thicker atmosphere
some scientists think that we could
release CO2 from the North and South
poles and this could make Mars's
atmosphere more like Earth's but a 2018
study published in nature astronomy
found that even if the nukes are
successful it would only increase Mars's
atmosphere to 7% of what Earth has even
if we create more carbon dioxide in
Mars's atmosphere it still wouldn't be
nearly enough to heat the planet and the
planet could seriously use more heat
heat since its current temperature
averages around -
63° and it would take decades for the
red planet to warm up even after it
gained the extra
CO2 So in theory this could delay humans
from ever landing on
Mars not only that but this assumes that
dropping thermonuclear bombs on the
planet would go perfectly keep in mind
these are nukes you know the things that
can destroy entire cities
in fact the bombs we'd use on Mars would
be 1,000 times stronger than the ones
used in World War II if a bomb exploded
on the planet's surface instead of up in
the atmosphere some severe damage would
occur Not only would it completely
destroy parts of the planet's surface it
would also cause even more radiation
another thing that would delay us from
ever settling on Mars it's also very
likely that instead of warming Mars a
bomb could cause a nuclear winter
this could happen from the dust and
particles in the atmosphere caused by
nuclear explosions they'd almost
entirely block out the sun causing Mars
to cool down even
more so nuking Mars probably isn't the
best idea we've heard about terraforming
the moon and Mars as we attempt to
colonize space but what about Venus if
we did manage to terraform our neighbor
one day it could look like
this could we live here one day how
different would it be from life on
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if we terraformed
Venus Believe It or Not Earth and Venus
are very similar at times Venus is even
referred to as Earth's sister Planet
they're both roughly the same diameter
have the same mass same gravity and are
both made out of the same material a
central iron core and a rocky mantle
unfortunately the comparisons end there
unlike Earth Venus is extremely hot has
an incredibly dense atmosphere and toxic
fumes on its surface what would we need
to do to make it
habitable scientists and astronomers
have been theorizing how to terraform
Venus for over half a century the two
biggest issues that need to be solved
are the atmosphere and the temperature
on Venus currently the surface of Venus
is a sweltering 462 de hot enough to
melt lead and the atmosphere made up
mostly of carbon dioxide is 93 times as
heavy as Earth's one proposed way of
altering Venus's atmosphere is to bomb
it with hydrogen hydrogen bombs when
reacting with the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere would create graphite and
water this would fall down to the
planet's surface and cover 80% of it
with oceans mind you they wouldn't be
nearly as deep as Earth's oceans Venus
would only have 10% the amount of water
that Earth has this would take a lot of
hydrogen the only way we could get
enough is if we were to harvest the
resource from Jupiter or Saturn this
approach would also require iron aerosol
a material that can be mined from
asteroids if all went according to plan
the dense carbon dioxide atmosphere
would be reduced to being just three
times as heavy as Earth's okay that's
manageable this would also help clear
the clouds of sulfuric acid that hang
over the planet okay the atmosphere is
clear now what about the temperature one
way to cool the surface is with solar
Shades a series of small spaceships or
one large lens that would divert the
Rays of the sun these solar Shades could
be placed on the surface of the planet
or in the atmosphere slowly working to
cool down the planet and reduce
radiation another issue that would need
to be resolved before we started Living
on Venus in addition to solar Shades
NASA thinks that we could build floating
cities Above the Clouds of Venus these
would work as a safe living space as we
learn and attempt to terraform the
environment to cool the planet even more
and to speed up the process cooling
pipes could be put on the surface of the
planet these pipes would take heat from
the surface and bring it up to colder
parts of the atmosphere now we have a
suitable atmosphere a proper temperature
and clean air but there's one other huge
issue that humans might have if they mve
to Venus they'd have extremely long days
and nights since Venus rotates once
every 243 Earth days meaning a day on
Venus is 5800 hours long not to mention
it's the only planet in our solar system
to rotate clockwise meaning that it's
extremely slow Sunrise would happen in
the west and sunsets would be in the
East we could create the illusion of a
24-hour day cycle by using massive
mirrors and having them rotate to
reflect the sun if this managed to work
correctly Venus would feel just like
home with maybe a touch less gravity
after all this Venus would finally be
habitable sure the planet would rotate
differently and you'd get a different
view of the Sun but it could be another
place for humans to live scientists
theorize that it could be a backup
Planet one day studying more about Venus
could teach us something about Earth
Venus suffers incredibly strong
Greenhouse effects the cause of its
extreme temperatures and dense
Atmosphere by learning more about
cooling this planet it may unlock the
secrets to cooling our own and maybe
make our home last even
longer this is a planetary emergency
evacuation please remain calm and board
your space
shuttles you know even though Humanity
might not have to leave the Earth in
your lifetime we should start preparing
early
on not only could it take centuries to
set up the relocation program it would
take generations to move to a potential
new
home that right there is is Proxima
centu b or just Proxima B it's the
closest potentially habitable planet out
there its temperatures are in the
bearable range and it could have just
the right breathable
atmosphere we only have to get
there how long would our journey last
how many people would we send to
populate the new world
successfully and what if it turned out
that Proxima B wasn't as as habitable as
we
thought this is what if and here's what
would happen if we relocated Humanity to
Proxima
be when astronomers started finding
planets outside our solar system or
exoplanets we realized that there are
many worlds out
there that meant that Earth doesn't have
to be our home
forever and that we don't have to die
with our planet when the sun engulfs it
some 5 billion years from
[Music]
now now that we found over 4,100
exoplanets we've learned something
rather
disappointing not all exoplanet smaller
than our yellow dwarf Sun it burns at a
lower
temperature it takes stars like Proxima
centu much longer to burn through all of
their hydrogen Supply Proxima centor
habitable
zone that means there's the potential
for liquid water and comfortable surface
temperatures if we're lucky Proxima B
would have an atmosphere that we could
breathe if it does the surface
temperatures would be in the range of
30° I don't know about you but I'd move
there right now I just need to warn you
that there are a few
problems a trip to Proxima B would be
long and very
dangerous Proxima B might be the closest
habitable exop planet we've got but that
doesn't mean it's
close the red dwarf star Proxima centu
is about 4.3 light years away that means
that if you could travel at the speed of
light it would take you 4.3 years to get
there nothing we've built so far can
reach that that kind of
speed realistically a trip to Proxima
centu in a space shuttle would take
165,000 years give or
take that's right some of the colonists
would be born in
transit some of them would never see the
Earth some of them would never see
Proxima
be they'd just live their lives aboard
the spaceship and die in
space how many humans would we need to
send on a mission
exactly it's so far that we can't even
see if it has an
atmosphere it might just happen that we
would arrive at a frozen planet with
surface temperatures of
-40° and even if it has an atmosphere it
might not be the right one we might
still enjoy warm temperatures but we'd
be doing that in space suits with oxygen
tanks
or Proxima B could be tidy locked to
Proxima centu meaning that one of the
planet sides would always face its star
and the other side would be plunged Into
Darkness space flight itself could bring
some unpleasant
surprises spending an entire lifetime in
a zerog gravity environment would lead
the crew members to lose muscle and bone
density they'd be constantly exposed to
space radiation their microbiomes immune
systems and Physiology would all be
different from
ours they wouldn't be the same kind of
humans as we are they would change their
values and culture they might forget all
the farming techniques we teach them to
sustain themselves in space and on their
new
planet they might change their mind
about the mission altogether and just
turn their spaceship in a different
direction
who knows they might even come back to
earth and take revenge for all those
years they were forced to spend in
space if that happens I'll be asking for
a
refund sending anyone on a mission like
this is a huge
risk we'd need to design and build a
vehicle choose the space Travelers very
carefully Supply them with all the food
and water and make sure they could
become self- sustaining
we'd have to design new propulsion
navigation hibernation and life support
systems and we have no way of knowing if
Proxima B is actually habitable well now
I don't really feel like going there do
[Music]
you
635 light years from where you are
sitting way out there and out outer
space lies a planet the first planet to
be discovered within the habitable zone
of a sunlike
star its name is Kepler
22b when a planet is located within a
star's habitable zone it means there is
a chance that liquid water exists on its
surface and where there's water there's
also the possibility of life human life
how long would it take to get to Kepler
22b what would the weather be like over
there and why would you need to get
jacked before arriving on this new
planet this is what if and here's what
would happen if you live on Kepler
22b Kepler 22b is what scientists call
an exoplanet it's a planet outside our
solar system spotting an exoplanet like
Kepler 22b is often not easy the bright
glare of the Stars they orbit tends to
keep them hidden from our
telescopes what did scientists come up
with to get around
in looking at the stars themselves to
see if they can find anything unusual
about them they spotted Kepler 22b using
What's called the transit method they
watched Kepler 22 the star this
exoplanet orbits around and noticed that
its brightness changes over time that
was because Kepler 22b was blocking the
Stars light with this scientists were
able to learn both the size of 22b and
how it orbits and it looks like this
distant Space Rock could become our next
home okay but what do we really know
about Kepler
22b its mass is 36 times that of Earth
with a radius of 2 and 1 half times
larger than ours one year on Kepler 22b
is 290 days it's also located 15% closer
to its star than we are to the
sun if Earth scooched over that close to
our star you'd be fried Kepler 22b on
the other hand is lucky to have a sun
that is remarkably similar to ours but
also smaller and cooler this close
proximity to its star allows the planet
to receive about the same amount of
sunlight as we get over here the
temperature on Kepler 22b could be about
15 to 22° C similar to Earth's Spring
weather and quite habitable if you ask
me but our galaxy can can be a cruel
place and not everything is good
news some models suggest Kepler 22b is
rotating on its side kind of like our
very own
Uranus this may sound insignificant but
it adds potentially deadly
complications this would mean that its
North and South poles are shrouded in
either Darkness or sunlight for half a
year and this ain't simply a matter of
whether you're a daytime or a nighttime
person a world like Kepler 22b spinning
on its side means that temperatures
could change from boiling to
freezing which wouldn't be great for
human
life I know what a bummer but don't
despair yet because our galaxy is also
big enough to include some hope new
studies suggest that Kepler 22b might be
covered in an ocean 50 m deep
and that ocean would be able to act as
natural climate control keeping the wild
temperatures at Bay you see an ocean can
store heat in the summer and release it
during the winter which results in a
mild climate like you needed another
reason to live close to the
water but hold on how would you even
make it all the way to Kepler
22b I mean even if you were traveling at
the speed of light it would take you
years your best bet could be to
hibernate through the trip inside a
device that preserves your body way past
its natural lifespan like cryogenic
sleep NASA has already developed a
cryosleep chamber that can lower an
astronaut's body temperature to as low
as 32°
CSUS this would trigger natural
hibernation during which cast catheters
would provide your body with nutrients
and remove any waste but even in cryo
sleep it would be quite the long risky
trip this leads us to the most dangerous
part about this journey All That Remains
Unknown about Kepler
22b for starters we still don't really
know what gravity is like there it could
be twice as strong as our planets if
that was the case a 10 kg sack of
potatoes would now weigh 20 kg and your
body would also factor into the mix is
your current weight 75 Kg well good luck
suddenly dealing with 150 kg of you and
just for safety settlers such as
yourself would need to bulk up really
bulk up only through intense strength
training would you increase your chances
of of being able to walk on Kepler
22b and once you got jacked on Earth
you'd have to figure out ways to
preserve that muscle through all
635 years of light speed
travel but humans aren't the only life
form that would be affected by a
stronger gravity plants brought from
Earth for oxygen and nutrition might not
survive on Kepler 22b when you try
growing them there and if you brought
any animals with you they'd need to step
up the evolution
process higher gravity could lead to
creatures developing additional legs to
move around it could also determine the
location and size of internal
organs but the Mysteries don't end there
scientists still don't know for sure
that Kepler 22b is even a rocky planet
it might be gous similar to Neptune or
it could be entirely covered with water
if you and the other first settlers woke
up from your cryo sleep and found
yourself on a gas planet yeah that would
be a downer you wouldn't have a solid
surface to even land your ship not to
mention a place to set up camp in that
case you and your crew would need to
figure out how to build a cloud city
orbiting the planet if you landed on an
ocean planet a submarine town would be
in
order discovering Kepler 22b is a rocky
planet would be hitting the jackpot then
right well not so fast Venus is also
made of rock and yet its dense
atmosphere consisting of greenhouse
gases makes it uninhabitable with
scorching temperatures far too hot for
liquid water if this was also the
situation with Kepler 22b how our only
chance at thriving on this exoplanet
would be to employ robots that could
build underground shelters the place
where maybe just maybe the temperature
might be cool enough for you to
Bear it just goes to show you that a
prime location is no guarantee for human
survival and as exciting as it might
seem to find other worlds to inhabit our
own Earth remains the perfect Habitat
for Humanity the Earth may not be our
home forever eventually we may have to
leave what if instead of finding a
potentially habitable exoplanet light
years away we stayed in our solar system
and built a habitat so enormous we could
never overpopulate
it this is what if and here's what would
happen if we built a ring World in
space imagine you lived on a ring with a
radius of 150 million km encircling the
Sun a gigantic artificial world with its
own gravity ecosystem and atmosphere big
enough for trillions of humans to call
home you'd live on an enormous land mass
on the inner side of the Ring the outer
shell would protect you and all those
trillions of people from the hazards of
outer space how does that sound yeah
great problem is assembling such a thing
suspended out in the solar system system
wouldn't be
easy you couldn't just pull the Earth
apart and have an army of robots
reassemble it into a ring
World among the many problems you'd run
into your first would be finding the
material the International Space Station
roaming the Earth's lower orbit right
now weighs about 420 tons something like
a ring world would tip the scales at no
less than a million tons where would we
find all this material I know some
places the Kyper belt beyond the orbit
of Neptune would do just fine this ring
of Icy B stretches out for almost three
billion
kilm some astronomers think the Kyper
belt would have enough material for this
project but it's hard to tell exactly
how much we'd need to construct a thing
like this we might have to sacrifice all
the planets moons and asteroids in the
solar system our ring world and the sun
would be the only things
left if we could manage to gather and
trans transport all the material
available then construction would begin
it would take a lot of physical labor an
army of robots and maybe hundreds of
generations to realize that our
structure was not stable enough because
the mega structure would turn out so
enormous it would break any known
molecular bonds we'd have to find a way
to make use of one of the fundamental
forces of nature the strong nuclear
force of all forces it's the grippiest
it bonds material on the scale of atom
IC nucleus so that nothing can break it
apart or maybe we'd come up with a new
super strong material altogether but
until we figure that out every
Interstellar body passing through our
solar system would be a threat to our
Mega structure the next thing we'd have
to worry about is gravity that part is
pretty easy we just have to spin the
Ring World at nearly 2 million
kmph I know that's really fast we'd have
to build up that speed over time luckily
maintaining it in the frictionless
environment of space wouldn't be too
hard such rotation would generate
centrifugal force and that in turn would
create an artificial gravity equal to
the one we have here on Earth with
gravity solved we bring in the
atmosphere and start populating the ring
world for the inhabitants of the mega
structure it would always be daytime
unless we could create a day and night
cycle with extra panels inside the ring
but for all the epicness of the world we
just created it wouldn't be stable
a single asteroid strike could cause the
structure to drift closer to the Sun a
hole punch through the ring could let
all our atmosphere out and a massive
solar storm don't even get me started on
that one one failure inside the ring
could Doom the entire structure together
with its inhabitants it's just too risky
to build it around the
[Music]
Sun
imagine living on the
[Music]
moon you'd have the best view of Earth
you'd enjoy bouncing around in zero
gravity and living your life as an
astronaut
Explorer doesn't that sound nice except
living on the moon won't be like this at
all so what would would it be like to
actually live on the
moon who will establish a base
first and why would moondust be your
biggest
problem this is what if and here's what
would happen if we settled on the
moon let's make this clear just like
America did in 1969 humans will land on
the moon again in the next decade only
this time it's expected to be more
permanent what's less clear is exactly
which country will be the first to land
and establish a base China the USA
Russia and India are all making strong
efforts to get there but there are also
private companies including SpaceX and
blue origin that have a lot more money
to spend on going to the moon but wait
why exactly are these companies doing
this in the first place apart from
exploring the Galaxy and breaking new
ground there's another huge reason these
groups all want to be the first to
create a base on the moon and that
reason is
money the Moon is chock full of
different resources it has gold silver
and titanium in it the idea here is to
mine these precious resources and send
them back to Earth another resource the
moon has is helium 3 it's incredibly
rare here on Earth but not on the moon
that's because the moon doesn't have an
atmosphere and helium 3 comes from the
sun's radiation over billions of years
the moon has been absorbing this
chemical and lucky for us it can be used
for energy helium 3 is so powerful that
just 100 kg of it could power the city
of Dallas Texas for an entire year oh
and it's also worth a cool $40,000 for
just 28 G of the stuff with these
resources holding incredible value it's
no sec secret these countries and
companies want to be the first to
establish a base but even if they do
they won't really own it back in 1967
the United Nations decided that no one
can really own space this has the
potential to cause huge tensions between
various Nations possibly leading to
war but enough about all that drama you
are on the
moon so how exactly are you going to
live here assuming we get to the moon in
one piece which is already an incredibly
difficult task on its own you'll then
have to worry about establishing a base
experts suggest that we live on the
moon's South Pole as it gets the most
consistent amount of sunlight there are
also massive fields of ice that we'll be
able to harvest some other places on the
moon don't get any sunlight for nearly a
month at a time luckily you'll have
robots to help you establish a base
there are many different ways they'll be
able to help one includes using Moon
soil to construct bricks and configuring
them in a dome like fashion sort of like
a moon
glue this would make traveling to the
Moon a lot cheaper as we wouldn't have
to bring everything from Earth to make
our base but don't expect this base to
be glamorous it'll most likely be
several meters underground to protect
you from the sun's radiation and as for
what you'll eat well it's will be your
standard dry astronaut food the good
news is that you should be able to grow
some carrots and tomatoes a 2014 Dutch
study found that it's possible using
soil on the Moon and what would you
drink unfortunately quite a lot of it
will be your recycled pee as drinking
water won't be available on the moon and
it would be too heavy to ship there
another thing you'll need to seriously
worry about is moond dust this magnetic
dust gets everywhere
it'll get on your suit and even on your
skin previous astronauts have had
allergic reactions to it it's also
slightly sharp so accidentally
swallowing any would be a huge problem
but it's not just humans who need to
worry about moondust it can get into
machines as well causing them to
overheat before we settle on the moon
this is one massive problem we'll need
to
solve all these issues beg the question
would you ever really want to be the
first to settle on the moon
you'd most likely spend your time Mining
and just surviving with little time to
run around in low gravity and besides we
all know that going here is just our
first baby step to get to Mars so maybe
you should just wait for
that in the universe Earth is clearly
the best for life
right wrong Earth may be great but
scientists have discovered a few worlds
that could be even better for
Life behold koi
[Music]
away the top spot is held by one 3,000
light years away from our solar
system koi
5751 would appear to satisfy the most
basic requirement for supporting life it
exists in the Goldilocks zone of its
star so conditions wouldn't be too hot
or too cold for a key life supporting
ingredient to exist on its surface
liquid water
but it would also check off many boxes
to be considered super habitable the
planetary system it belongs to could be
52 billion years old which would make it
around 1 billion years older than our
own solar system and the planet would
almost fit the size requirement when
looking for superhabitable worlds
scientists keep their eyes peeled for
planets that have a mass up to 1 and a
half times of our planet and they should
be about 10% larger too this size
difference would help the planet retain
heat and if its average temperature was
about 5° C higher than Earth's well this
planet could have even richer
biodiversity now being almost double the
size of Earth koi 571
5.01 might overshoot this condition a
bit besides studies indicate that this
planet is actually colder than Earth but
there's still hope with the right
atmospheric composition a strong
greenhouse effect could raise
temperatures to the desired level and as
far as super habitable worlds go well
we're just getting
started approximately 2700 light years
away is Kepler
69c this superar could be around 7
billion years old this puts it perfectly
in the estimated 5 to 8 billion year old
age range for superhabitable planets
this range is based on the 3 and A2
billion years it took for complex life
to appear on Earth so the best chance
for finding life could be on a planet a
little older than us only this exoplanet
could be a little too big to be super
habitable it has a Mass almost four
times that of Earth a rocky planet this
big could have a single colossal
continent that would have huge deserts
in its Center but the coastline Washed
by Kepler's ocean could be your perfect
spot to move
to our next Super Earth shares a similar
name Kepler
1126b except it would be located ever so
slightly closer to home yeah this planet
is about
273 light years away and it belongs to a
system that is 7 and A2 billion years
old it also orbits a yellow dwarf star
much like our own only Kepler 1126b is 2
and a half times closer to its star than
Earth is to the Sun but that's no big
deal because the star Kepler 1126b
orbits is cooler than ours so the
habitable zone would exist in a Range
much closer in proximity to
it if you aren't feeling this nearness
to a scorching hot star there's another
Super Earth on our list and it's at a
reasonable distance from
home speculo 2C is located only 106
light years away not that its proximity
gives it any kind of advantage
it would still take you well over
200,000 years to travel to this super
Earth and that's if you moved at the
speed of NASA's Parker solar probe the
fastest probe ever
launched speculo 2C does look promising
though it's about 40% larger than Earth
there's also the potential for it being
a rocky planet just like ours now
despite the fact that it also exists in
the habitable zone its red dwarf star is
still very small it's only about 15% the
size of our sun so this planet orbits
around its star at a very close distance
and this close distance could mean that
speculo 2C is tidally locked to its
star this super Earth takes 8 and 1/2
days to make one full rotation on its
axis as well as one orbit around its
star that would leave one side of the
planet in constant daylight and the
other in Endless Night this means that
life could be possible in The Terminator
Zone the thin strip of land between the
two sides we just need to get a better
look to find out for
sure this is not some DVD floating in
space it's a Mega structure that might
One Day become Humanity's
home the Earth might not remain
habitable forever it could get engulfed
by a massive solar flare or become too
hot due to climate change or have all
its life wiped out by one enormous
asteroid what if I told you we could
outlive all these
disasters and that we could do that
by building a space Mega structure
Bigger Than The Sun
itself just how big would we have to
make
it and what would life be like on a
structure like
that this is what if and here's what
would happen if we could build an
Alderson
disc why would we colonize other
currently uninhabitable planets if we
could hypothetically Al build a habitat
of our own something that would host
many billions of future humans without
ever running out of
space it does look like a DVD doesn't it
only it has the mass of 3,000
Suns the reason why we'd need our
Alderson disc to have such a huge mass
is
gravity all objects with mass are
gravitationally drawn to each other and
objects with a greater mass have a
greater gravitational
pull for the Alderson disc to be stable
enough to host life we'd need it to have
a stronger pull than the sun
does that's where it gets tricky because
the sun is the most massive object in
our solar system accounting for
99.8% of its total mass to have enough
material to outweigh the Sun we'd have
to get it by breaking down every planet
Moon and asteroid in a radius of
hundreds of light years around
us or we could give our Alderson disc
artificial gravity this type of gravity
isn't caused by attraction but by
acceleration or centrifugal force in
other words we'd have to spin our dis
fast enough that it doesn't collapse
into a donut or get swallowed by the Sun
but since we haven't really figured out
artificial gravity yet let's stick with
the first option and make our Alderson
disc very very massive
241 million km
wide that would make it stretch past the
orbit of Mars it would also be several
thousand kilm or miles thick and would
have a surface area equivalent to over 1
billion Earths
just imagine how many billions of humans
could live on
it ah but not so fast our Alderson disc
wouldn't be habitable
everywhere and before I explain that let
me talk about the Sun for a
moment our sun would be sitting
stationary in the hole at the center of
the disc and because of this our disc
would have no day and night cycle only a
NeverEnding
Twilight but since our disc would have a
bigger mass and a stronger gravitational
pull there's a chance that the sun would
wobble up and down that would somewhat
solve our day and night problem but it
could also increase the possibility of
colliding with our
star we might need to install gamma ray
lasers to have more control over the
sun's wobbling and still still our
disc-shaped world would need way more
things to become suitable for us to live
on
it one of the most important things is
an
atmosphere on Earth the atmosphere
protects us from harmful ultraviolet
radiation it reduces temperature
extremes and it creates pressure that
allows liquid water to
exist we'd need an atmosphere to do all
the same things for our Alderson disc
and to to keep the Sun from stealing it
we'd need to build a wall around the
disc's inner
Edge unlike Earth the Alderson disc
wouldn't have liquid metal in its core
to give it a
magnetosphere a magnetic field is
important because it keeps the solar
wind from stripping off the
atmosphere without it the solar wind
would erode the part of the Alderson
disc closer to the
Sun this could make the entire structure
unstable and possibly destroy it
altogether once we figure out how to
make the atmosphere and magnetic field
we could bring in
water we'd make holes in the disc that
would allow for
oceans because of the way gravity would
work on our Alderson disc the water
could be
suspended the oceans on the disc-shaped
structure would literally be
bottomless for the same gravitational
reasons humans would be able to live on
both the top and the bottom side of the
disc for those living on the bottom side
it wouldn't feel as if they were walking
upside down it would be just normal on
each
side but of course this space Mega
structure could have some
flaws because of the disc's enormous
Mass its gravity might make it collapse
into a gigantic Taurus or even worse a
black hole
then there are
asteroids even though we used up all the
nearby asteroids to form our Alderson
disc in the first place there's no
guarantee new Interstellar space rocks
wouldn't come and bombard our disc world
and not just asteroids but rogue planets
as
well even the slightest hit could
destabilize the disc and plunge it right
into the
sun speaking of the Sun remember I said
that not all of the Alderson disc would
be habitable that's because the sun
wouldn't be heating it
evenly the inner side of the disc would
be very hot to withstand the tremendous
heat we'd have to give our disc a heat
shield just like the one we developed
for the Parker solar
probe the outer edges of the disc would
be freezing cold but the middle band of
the structure would be just perfect for
Life although there would be a lot of
unused space the habitable area would
still be 50 million times larger than
the entire surface of
Earth so a giant platter with the
thickness of several thousand
kilom it might not survive in
space make room Earthling we're moving
the other planets in our solar system
into our planetary neck of the woods
would all the planets fit into this
goldilock
Zone what kinds of gravitational chaos
would this
cause and does this mean life would
exist on the other
planets this is what if and here's what
would happen if all the planets of the
solar system were in the habitable zone
liquid water is a key ingredient for
life and in our solar system earth is
the only planet with liquid water on its
surface that's because our planet is
located in the habitable zone of our sun
also known as the Goldilocks zone and
the conditions here are just right any
closer and water would boil away any
further it would freeze
the size of this area depends on how hot
or cool a star is scientists have
discovered 4,000 exoplanets within
habitable zones but only 24 of them
might be able to support life in our
solar system this zone is within a range
of 0.9 to
1.2 astronomical units from the
Sun so if we park all the other planets
within this 45 million kilm patch of
real estate could we Kickstart
extraterrestrial
life with eight planets to Squeeze In
the goldilock Zone you'd need to get
creative the last thing you'd want to do
would be disrupt the conditions for life
on Earth right well to start this
scenario off you'd need to move Mercury
to the innermost portion of the
habitable Zone at around 0.9
astronomical units that would be more
than twice as far away from the Sun as
Mercury orbits now not much would change
on this rocky planet except for a
refreshing coolness after billions of
years of scorching hot
temperatures Venus already orbits
relatively close to the habitable zone
at
0.72 astronomical units when our sun was
was a young star and dimmer Venus was
essentially located in a habitable zone
it could even have had conditions for
life with a shallow ocean of its own but
as the sun got hotter that goldilock
zone was pushed further back
temperatures increased and the oceans
boiled away maybe relocating Venus to a
cooler spot away from the Sun could make
it habitable once again
now it would be time to do some
calculating you've got five more planets
to squeeze in it could be a good idea to
make sure all the planets are an equal
distance apart with our narrow goldilock
Zone you could place each planet 6 and2
million km from each other that would be
equal to about 30 times the distance
between the Earth and the moon moving us
away from our current location would
make this whole experiment a little less
chaotic but at about 0.97 astronomical
units things would get warmer here bad
news for the climate
crisis uh ignoring that for now you'd
move on to Mars you'd be excited to see
if this cold rocky planet could have
life well sorry to say it would still be
Barren you see liquid water isn't the
only thing that life needs to thrive
Mars lacks a magnetic field that means
solar radiation would strip away the
chances of it having an atmosphere you'd
still have to terraform it You' likely
not see any life popping up on the
remaining gish's planets either the gas
giants Jupiter and Saturn have
atmospheric pressures and temperatures
far too intense for molecules like DNA
to be stable but you could probably take
a cold dip on one of Jupiter's moons
Europa its new proximity to the sun
would allow its thick ice layer to melt
feeling refreshed you'd realize that the
last planet in our solar system Neptune
is now even closer to us than Mars is
today that means in our new solar system
Arrangement planet hopping would be a
reasonable Adventure even with current
technology you could travel between the
planets in 90 days and Beyond the
exploration there are all kinds of
resources you could extract from the
other planets you could get hydrogen
fuel from Jupiter and Saturn to help us
transition to a low carbon future you
could mine Cobalt from asteroids this
would be important to developing
renewable energy
systems but this new solar system would
be a little unstable to say the least
especially with a massive Planet like
Jupiter so close to us it has 2 and a
half times the mass of all the other
planets in our solar system
combined scientific reports indicate a
star similar to our sun could have six
earth-sized planets within its habitable
zone with Jupiter gravitational
stability would be all out of whack and
all these imbalances could result in the
planets or moons getting ejected from
orbit or reshuffled
completely it's one of Humanity's most
ambitious undertakings created to extend
human exploration to the farthest
reaches of our solar
system the next step in space
exploration isn't Generations away it's
happening right now and our destination
that mysterious and desolate world next
door
Mars imagine starting life over on that
tiny red dot over
265 million km
away what would happen if we built a
City on
Mars would you have to live
underground how many people would you
live
with and what would the Martian economy
look
like this is what if and here's what
would happen if we built a city on
Mars since
1975 the only things from Earth making
claims on Mars are robots and
satellites but now Elon Musk and his
company SpaceX are looking to change
that story their goal to create a city
with a government trade and culture on
Mars this plan involves 1,000 spaceships
and even more Brave new
recruits by surviving in lower gravity
with fewer people and only limited
supplies living on Mars might change how
we could adapt to dwindling resources on
Earth but with so much depending on the
early stages of planning and Supply runs
could Life on Mars be
sustainable every great city starts
small whether you're talking about the
little fishing town of Hong Kong or a
Hut Village named Rome so if you want
this Martian colony to grow into a
thriving City you're going to need more
than a handful of people according to
the Bordeaux Institute National poly
technique you would need at least 110
settlers to start this adventure the
SpaceX plan starts with two spaceships
carrying 100 people each with this
handful of explorers your city would
have just enough people to build more
habitats and research stations without
putting your resources in danger if you
run out of food at this stage that's the
end of the
experiment the biggest challenge this
city faces is becoming sustainable
without relying on regular shipments
from Earth which will only come every
few years you see with the egg-shaped
orbit of Mars it takes
687 Earth days to make one Martian year
Supply runs would only love launch when
Earth and Mars align which happens every
2 years to cut down on travel time
between our worlds and after this nearly
8 month long trip there's still a chance
of losing all those supplies when the
rocket lands since the gravity on Mars
is only 38 of the pull on Earth Landing
safely on the surface of Mars would be
dangerous and that doesn't take into
account the amount of dust flying in the
air after all the dust on the moon was
bad enough and it got into crew members
eyes and damaged systems on their
spacecraft but kicking up the dust on
Mars might be even more deadly since
each grain is highly oxidized and
electrically charged but hey you made it
to Mars
safely now what are you going to
eat the chlorinated soils un Mars are
toxic and if you ingested them with your
food you might damage your thyroid gland
so that means farming is out outdoor
farming at least well before you worry
about eating you'll need to set up
protection from the harsh conditions on
Mars with an atmosphere made of 95%
carbon dioxide the air on Mars is toxic
and don't forget about the intense
radiation on the surface with more
exposure to radiation and no breathable
air you won't be able to survive without
a controlled environment thankfully with
the help of those rocks under your feet
you have all the protection you need
just 5 m of the surface materials on
Mars called regolith provides the same
amount of shielding from radiation as
Earth's atmosphere this material would
be processed into cement to create
layered walls using robots and 3D
printers
this material would be a protective
shell and underneath that shell do
science facilities Living Spaces and all
your home
Comforts connected by tubes these domes
would provide you Shelter From the
Raging dust storms outside which might
last for months even with this
technology Elon Musk claims it could
take up to 10 years to establish a
colony but it's during this time that
your quaint Martian Village would grow
into the first human City beyond Earth
since this world isn't being drilled or
fracked the power grid on Mars can be
made sustainable right from the start we
would set up solar arrays for
electricity and use natural gases like
methane for engines our footprint on
Mars could start low and stay that way
no matter how many people live there and
now you better figure out a way to feed
all these people the low gravity on Mars
might decrease your muscle mass to keep
your body healthy you'll need to provide
more protein you'll have to serve the
equivalent of 110 cooked chicken breasts
and 660 carrots every day if one of
these domes contained an indoor Farm you
could raise the chickens you need to
feed your city and you would have the
most nutrient-rich manure available if
you used this manure in the green houses
you'd have a way to fertilize your crops
year round but how could you irrigate
those crops how would you get
water scientists still debate whether
liquid water exists below the ice caps
on Mars but if it does exist that
freshwater Source could be filtered for
the colonists to use for irrigation
with less gravity on Mars pulling water
down into the ground you would need less
water to keep your plants alive than you
would on Earth since it would stay
closer to the surface and with supplies
being transported only every 2 years
having Spring Water available on Mars
would change how the city would operate
it would create a government
infrastructure to distribute and oversee
the water supply and employ scientists
to man manage the filtration needs now
the city has an infrastructure in place
and jobs to fill so how would you value
your time in terms of cash how could you
pay for products or
Services cash weighs too much to travel
with in outer space and credit cards
would require Wi-Fi services
communicating back to Earth with a
14-minute gap in Communications between
Mars and Earth eh you're going to need
need something more locally
based well you might have to use a
cryptocurrency known as marscoin but you
would have need to have bought it with
your Earth money before you boarded the
spaceship while marscoin would only be
available to martians this money would
help build the government increase trade
and create a standard of living with
Society on Mars still new maybe you
could trade your services or learn to
barter Goods instead of relying on this
cash
system if we do things right Life on
Mars might be the model for future
civilizations free from the constraints
of the culture built on Earth or it
could be like every sci-fi movie ever
made before you go on to the next
hypothetical Adventure have a look at
our what if 100 book this is your
must-have Encyclopedia of imaginations a
beautiful collection of your 100
favorite scenarios amazing artworks and
interesting facts all in good old
beautiful print and
[Music]
paper
one day Mars could look like
[Music]
this allowing humans to comfortably live
on the planet all we'd need to do is to
terraform it but
how well we could nuke
it would dropping nukes on Mars make it
easier to live there
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we nuked
Mars believe it or not this is something
scientists have considered for
decades Elon Musk of SpaceX seems to
think that nuking Mars might be one of
the best and quickest options